elle est tantôt nar
respect absolu
très en forme à un fémur
merci à tous bien alors la bomba il ya
une légende d'une légende de cantona
fait à la fois de deux génies du
football est à la fois de rébellion
contre l'ordre établi et c'est pour ça
que vous êtes le bienvenu et alors dans
cette famille cantona il y avait un
oncle ermite et c'est important pour la
suite parce que ça vous a sûrement
beaucoup influencé qui vivait au fin
fond de l'ardèche qui avait une barbe
jusqu'au nombril qui avaient des chèvres
qui a sommé les truites qui pêchaient
dans la rivière sur des rochers qui
mangeaient des fruits qui cueillait des
salades des prêts qui buvait l'eau des
rivières est un personnage que vous
n'avez pas rencontré mais qui a dû
beaucoup vous vous marque est en forme
en jeu c'est mon idole moi je n'ai
jamais connu j'ai mes bonnes par rapport
à ce que ma grand mère a le don de
raconter les histoires dont nous faire
rêver elle est arrivée à me faire aimer
quelqu'un que je ne connais pas mon
imaginaire ces monnaies doit vous avez
l'enfance aux caillols à marseille qu'un
quartier moitié-moitié village moitié
hlm enfin non on peut dire ça
un bon manu c'est un village et puis
maintenant c'est devenu des hlm
alors très tôt il ya deux traits
dominants chez vous eric cantona c'est à
dire le génie du foot ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que très
jeune aux caillols quand vous arriviez
comme ça sur un terrain
on disait tiens voilà le soleil qui
entre donc le génie du foot très tôt et
puis rébellion contre l'ordre établi
votre grand mère lucienne dit qu'à
l'époque déjà très jeune il y a dix lui
les injustices il les accepte pas moi
j'aime les gens qui
qui réagit ce qu'ils font et rue par
rapport à ce qu'ils ressentent c'est
lent du coeur quaprès après à l'édition
rebelles je fais des trucs deux robes
ayant alors c'est à vous qui le dites
c'est moi non mais c'est vrai mais
si les gens le disent entre eux ou les
trucs comme ça limite ça mais c'est à
peine que je vous dise à la télévision
cela me gêne comme le disent à moi
ça te met en état de rébellion quand ils
te disent alors pas du tout mais la
passe comme si je devais être fier de ce
que j'ai fais quoi je ne viens jamais
raconter ce que j'ai fait j'en étais
fier de ce que je faisais je faisais
j'ai fait des trucs comme tout le moins
je me suis rebellé certaines choses je
me suis après bon ben vous avez eu un
itinéraire qui comme j'étais la
légendaire en dents de scie avec des
moments formidables démons d'abattement
terrible
très proche je passe vous faire plaisir
je vous dis ça mais moi je vous ai adoré
dans le film de becker les enfants du
marais vous jouez le boxeur cette
formidable semble un très beau fils très
beau film et les sites web auront ils
été très bonne à vous avez vu déjà dans
quelques films mais là je te dire que
d'un seul coup c'était vraiment vous
c'est à dire à un moment j'ai la peine
je lui dis oui il va pouvoir le faire
sans match j'espère quand même que pour
le faire son match et puis non on
comprend qu'il va rester en prison qui a
pas faire son match et voilà mais c'est
un peu c'est un peu le résumé de votre
vie ce film ouais j'ai vécu des trucs
comme ça il ya des grandes compétitions
que j'ai eu envie de jouer des grands
matches que je viens de jouer comme a
empêchés de jouer alors qu un non match
a donné tant de choses et qu'on te prive
de ça
mais bon c'est pas grave guy roux c'est
le premier qui vise à repérer ouais en
fait une de ses adjoints qui m'a repéré
20 et donc à 15 ans vous allez allez j
serre et l'appareil ça commence joya
mais je sais pas si c'est vrai mais un
dénommé martini vous déblayer la
déblayer le terrain nettoyé mais de la
neige sur le terrain c'est à dire qu'on
devait jouer un match de stages d'été
c'était année j'ai correctement mais guy
roux c'est des joueurs c'est nous qui
devions enlever la neige et on enlevait
tout cela neige sauf
sauf martin non mais bon c'est pas grave
parce que c'est quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup j'estime beaucoup je me suis
rattrapé avec lui et ça m'a
je vais je les ai découverts à partir de
ce jour là alors oui c'est ça et depuis
je l'aimais énormément quand on sait les
disputes en couple en famille ou entre
amis vous apporte beaucoup de choses
alors vous êtes prêté à vous être prêté
à martigues vous êtes beaucoup été prêté
ces relais les patrons de clubs après ça
a été le cas de tapis les patronnes club
à un moment cantona bon ça commençait un
peu à [ __ ] le bordel alors ils le
prétendaient que la pesée de prêter à
martigues on partait à martigues c'est
très bien parce que vous en profitiez
d'ailleurs pour rencontrer retrouver
isabelle donc tout va bien après alors
après tapis vous convainc d'aller à
marseille de vie une proposition
importante du matra racing lagardère et
tapis vous convainc en disant tu es
marseillais tu dois venir à marseille
non c'est moi qui me suis dit je suis
marseillais je vais avoir envie de la
mersey vous avez déjà quand vous le dise
quoi
à l'époque c'est quand même le plus gros
transfert de l'histoire du football à 22
millions de france en quelle année sa
89 incessamment ce transfert le plus
cher de l'époque
aujourd'hui je pense pas comme eux c'est
con mais un transfert au joueur de
deuxième division norman et anelka il a
touché sa l'année le cas pour venir au
psg sait combien je parle de 150 ou 250
précis dix fois plus voilà cinq ans dix
ans vous auriez dû faire footballeur en
10 ans voit aussi en disant c'est à
multiplier par dix services les 22
millions c'était à l'époque tout le
monde y est c'est extraordinaire et
maintenant c'est 220 millions voilà
bon l'om au début ça marche pas très
bien mais vous ça vous plaît pas ce que
vous dites quand on doute de moi je
deviens bon on va me jetez pas vos rangs
ouais
moi je commençais à douter de moi rue
mais non mais ces jeux je devais pas
retourner à marseille ouais parce que je
suis parti jeune je suis parti à 15
heures j'aurai mal vécu la vie que je
devais vivre et je suis arrivé là-bas et
j'ai vécu j'ai vécu toutes les villes
sauf celle là que doit vivre un sportif
de haut niveau ouais et mais par contre
ça m'a servi pour la soirée ouais alors
si cette époque aux vêtements ou vous
disputez avec henri michel qui vous
sélectionne pas dans l'équipe de france
contre la tchécoslovaquie et on a à
l'époque faut dire la vérité vous étiez
copain avec mickey rourke et mickey
rourke il était en france il est la
promotion d'un film s'appelait homeboy
est aussi copain avec lui et mieux
cléroux que sa furia il avait dit en
parlant des oscars d'hollywood c'est un
truc de sac à merde et filles de la mort
cantona qui était son pote il sent bien
trop grand ils sont bien trouvés tous
les deux et un moment vous avez déclaré
koreï michel est un sac à merde
évidemment sa part j'ai dit ce que je
pensais à ce moment là ouais mais
voilà mais bon c'est des trucs là c'est
dans l'histoire qui sont pas très très
grave quoi parce que des fois avant les
mots se dépassent
la pensée où les mots ne sommes pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'on pense ouais mais non
ce que j'essaie de dire là en fait c'est
que ce qui vous à ce qu'a fait de vous
un personnage légendaire par rapport à
d'autres très bon footballeur mais qui
sont pas des légendes c'est qu'il y
avait à la fois ce génie du foot
évidemment il n'est il y avait aussi
cette espèce d'attitude comme ça et
c'est ça qui vous qui a créé l'image de
cantona de conto qu'on va commencer à
vous appeler à l'époque d'ailleurs je
suis pas en tous les cas ça m'a
non aujourd'hui ces villes parce qu'on a
réussi quelque chose
qu'est-ce qui se
passerait si elle vous allume ne vous
étonnez pas de terreur j'arrivais un but
à faire l'interview
énoncé quand je vais en parler de quoi
là non
on disait que ce qui vous a ce qui vous
à ce qu'a fait l'image de cantona mais
je crois que ce que moi je conseillerais
jamais à un jeune de de vivre et de
faire ce que j'ai fait parce que c'est
vraiment dur
c'est dur
j'ai souffert et
j'ai laissé des plumes ouais et ses
fenêtres
fois trop bon déjà pour arriver à se
faire accepter parce qu'au début des
gens maintenant la tendance s'est
renversée parce qu'il ya eu des
performances ouais sur le terrain oui
mais au départ on voulait tous les packs
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque elle est où les
gens aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui kim et kiki même ont été les
premiers à me détruire mais après on
arrive à renverser la tendance parce
qu'on est sur le terrain on fait ce
qu'il faut oui et sur un terrain on fait
ce qu'il faut en se préparant et en
prenant des trucs à néant les épaules
mais après faut assurer c'est simple il
faut assurer plus on emmerde les genres
sa personne bah oui je pensais je
connaissais sa personne parce que je
pense que si j'avais pas vécu cette vie
peut-être que j'aurais fait mieux que ce
que j'ai fait même si quelque part ça
m'a motivé on va le voir alors bon je
veux pas raconter tout et j'ai besoin de
ça et l'époque à sedan contre le torpédo
ou à la 27e minute vous balancer le
ballon dans les tribunes vous engueuler
que l'arbitré et vous et vous jetez le
maillot à terre ce qui évidemment est
même tapis qu'à l'époque nommé député
enfin élu député il vous soutenez plus à
ce moment-là trépied
non il m'a jamais soutenu ouais il
disait en parlant de vous s'il faut le
mettre en clinique en le mettant en
clinique ouais moi on aurait pu se
retrouver
bon là
on va pas on va pas tout faire mais
c'est vrai que là vous êtes prêté à
bordeaux puis à montpellier et serra et
il ya une bagarre dans les vestiaires du
club montpellier et le problème c'est là
que ça commence le vrai problème parce
que jusque là seul encore l'entraîneur
sait aimé jacquet
ouais voilà et là
est ce que vous pensez pas que
finalement ce qui vous a conduit à tout
ça c'est une espèce de désir de pureté
absolue de ne pas vouloir accepter les
règles du jeu c'est le cas de le dire
enfin pas du jeu sur le terrain mais du
jeu en dehors du terrain non ce que ce
que j'ai fait je les fais pour moi
certaines fois parce que j'en avais
besoin et je les fais aussi pour
l'équipe quand je sentais que ça allait
pas je pense être quelqu'un de loin
d'être intelligent pas du tout
intelligent peut être un truc un stand
chiffres jeu je sens quand on a besoin
des choses c'est un sport collectif on a
besoin abandonné d'un leader ou quelque
chose qui fait qu'il ya un choc
psychologique et pas obligatoirement ne
change le changement d'entraîneur ou les
trucs comme ça une bagarre sur un
terrain à partir de ce jour-là
montpellier on en a on a gagné beaucoup
de matches en ligue 1 on a gagné
là on a gagné la coupe de france et
trucs comme ça je pense que c'est des
moments comme ça qu'il faut
qu'il faut avancer qui font avancer
piana money qui se séparent il y en a
qui se regroupent et abandonnée on finit
que si on a envie de faire quelque chose
ensemble soit un avis on n'a pas mis ici
au pied du mur comme moi les gens qui
ont vraiment envie de faire une chose
comme les hommes et swan et des hommes
ce n'est pas des zones et si on arrive à
faire quelque chose on est au pied du
mur on se serre les coudes et on fait
que les ont réussi un truc et cholet
chose la nasa elle allait elle se dit
c'est un vrai rallye savent réduit alors
là
avis c'est que tu as froid prévoir à
boire et wii voit alors donc bon voilà
et là vous arrêter le football à ce
moment là pour la première fois donc
vous réfugier dans une espèce de
claustration un peu ni liste comme ça
vous dit que finalement les joueurs sont
des sondés machine à marquer vous faites
des interviews vous raconter que j'ai
des rêves un peu un peu halluciné des
réveils entre arras et comme ça c'est
cette époque raconter ça mais les mines
qui a dit attendez il ya une interview
dans l'actuelle vous vous dites je suis
pilote d'avion je suis arrêtée à un feu
rouge à s'imposer dans la fierté et
j'essayais de l'interpréter où nous
essayer de voir des gens qui m'ont aidé
et interpréter ce genre de truc mais ça
c'est ce que vit tout le monde tous les
jours moi je serai bien le rêve qu elle
voulait c'est la vision c'est partir
c'est les besoins de liberté ces
différentes zones de trucs même dans le
ciel comme ça y'a des feux rouges et
l'avion s'arrête il ya un trafic monstre
et le cndd besoin de liberté ça peut
nous croissons pression pour nous
ok
en tous les cas c'est l'époque vous êtes
plus intéressés vous dites vous même
avec cantona par la souffrance de
l'artiste que parle que parle que par le
football mais comme vous devez encore du
pognon à nîmes je veux dire la vérité et
votre contrat vous deviez 7 millions
faisait encore deux ans et demi de
contrat mais j'ai large payez vous avez
payés oui bien sûr je vois vous n'êtes
pas payé non non je devais payer puisque
je devais arrêter et puis j'ai pas
arrêté mais je m'étais avancée s'est
déjà engagé à payer
je me suis engagé à payer je m'étais
engagé à payer 7 millions ouais moi ce
que je devais et là il avait payé et là
c'est pour ça que je raconte tout ça
c'est pour montrer sa sauce ps2 resort
vous allez à ce moment là vous avez
marre vous partez en angleterre alors
vous vous le savez ici à peut-être des
gens qui le 5 mai les téléspectateurs ne
savent pas tous moi je ne savais pas
vraiment vous partez en angleterre ça
commence avec sheffield voilà le coach
il va vous mettre à l'essai vous dites
on ne met pas quand on a laissé juste
pas vous allez à leeds est alors voilà
c'est le début de votre deuxième
carrière qui est peut-être moins connue
que la première puisque ça se passe en
angleterre enfin il ya eu en angleterre
une quand thomas n'ya absolument
délirantes il y avait il y avait les
supporteurs il s'appelait l'armée dingue
de cantona c'était un groupe de un
groupe de supporteurs de vous il avait
des maillots de l'équipe de france qui
pour les anglais comme extraordinaire et
chanté la marseillaise et donc vous
allez ses phrases formidable qui ont
séduit les anglais c'est iloveyou faille
don't know why peut-être face à lézat
exploser tout ce que ça veut dire ça i
love your est un big aux
danois et un bataille love you michel
madern fatale attiré plus d'une avec ça
comme quoi des fois c'est pas la peine
d'avoir un vocabulaire très
mal à ça les a séduits love you don't
know why bataille la douce et les a
séduits qui n'est passé du canton quand
on a un français un peu costaud qui vous
disent est un bon joueur
mais j'ai absolument vous cacher mais je
suis persuadé que vous aviez un jules
vous et je vous dirai pas ah bon
j'ai garde le mystère de la chanson
bien alors là vous êtes à manchester
donc manchester champion d'angleterre
c'est à ce moment là que la france est
éliminée de la coupe
du mondial la france est éliminée contre
la bulgarie à cette époque-là 2 1 et si
vous aviez une suffisance à l'époque
l'équipe de france et vous pensiez tout
ce que vous alliez aller en amérique
maintenant il fallait qu'on prenne un
point on avait deux matches à jouer et
un au parc contre israël et la bulgarie
ouais mais vous étiez persuadé que
j'allais aller en amérique il disait ta
femme arrive à toi non la mienne ne
vient pas c'est à dire vous y étiez déjà
et gt gt au parcours au dernier moment
on mettait des manteaux et puis que ce
sont dix neuf
fini comme pour l'italie mais dans un
des sept centres et cette fois c'est
voilà
et là il vous restait plus qu'une coupe
du monde avant la retraite vous êtes dit
celle-là je vais pas y aller il m'en
reste une ses 98
1 on y vient on y vient doucement
d'abord en 95 il ya eu au christ il ya
eu la sphère du crystal palace
et c'est là
c'est là que
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup dire
c'est la cas cette phrase extraordinaire
d'eric cantona quand les mouettes
suivent le chalutier c'est qu'elles
pensent qu'on va leur jeter des sardines
cette phrase impérissable d'eric cantona
a été prononcé en ce moment là c'était
ça nous est venue comme enjeu face
non il venait d'y avoir le procès et
puis je venais d'être fait jaser les
payer que ouais puis avait il y avait
toute une journaliste puis vous les caps
tout prix que j'aille parler que
j'allais dire de moi et vous avez sorti
quand les mouettes suivent le chalutier
ça veut dire quoi sert le chien n'a rien
mais ça c'est rien mais j'aurais pu dire
le rideau hall et rose moi je le vois
roissy toi tu le vois d'oreilles c'est
pas grave il ya des lumières et puis on
sait demain vous ai dit ça comme ça quoi
mais c'est resté parler pour parler
hilton quoi alors manchester mal malgré
l affaire crystal palace manchester vous
garde le seul qui veut plus de vous sait
aimé jacquet et à partir de là vous êtes
barré dans l'équipe de france pas relax
zidane djorkaeff
donc vous faites pas l'euro 96
à une époque ça doit être terrible pour
vous parce que l'angleterre c'était
l'époque de votre plus grande gloire en
angleterre il vu des sondages où la
majorité des hommes anglais préféré
passer a déclaré qu'il aurait préféré
passer leurs vacances avec cantona
plutôt qu'avec cindy crawford s'est fait
dire que vous avez une cote en
angleterre fait s'il dit à l'apéro et
vient pas
non mais les tee shirts est avec marc
god comme ça
160 millions de france a rapporté en une
année à manchester ce qui était plus que
la vente des billets du club pendant un
an à un moment vous avez une côte énorme
en angleterre et en france vous êtes
barré dans l'équipe de france parce que
jacquet pense que si vous allez dans le
fameux collectif vous allez [ __ ] le
bordel dans ses skis par an soit 1 voilà
il est venu vous le dire c'est vrai
parce qu'il raconte dans son livre de
mémoires aimé jacquet qui les vit en
angleterre vous expliquer ça il est
vraiment venu vous voir il est venu mais
j'étais dans une fête
il m'a donné rendez vous je suis arrivé
deux heures après je crois que même fait
chier pas si j'étais venu me dire c'est
ouais oui c'était pour me dire autre
chose et puis à 9 h avec moi je sais que
c'est une guérilla pour atteindre 2
heures le bien baril puis finalement il
m'a dit autre chose ce serait terrible
ça mais je sais pas attendu saw et
jamais je laisse avant tout c'est un
scénario de film génial imaginer qu'il
ait fait le voyage aimé jacquet pour
vous dire finalement bien ce qu'il a
jamais dit ça mais moi je le dis
aujourd'hui plein fouet ils doivent
jamais dit pour se défendre de quoi que
ce soit ré dans là quelque part c'est
quelqu'un
il peut être respectable mais ouais pour
ça maintenant vous allez éteindre la
lumière chez vous et ici aussi
alors eric cantona cette décision de pas
vous faire jouer en équipe de france en
98 qui est pas été du tout comprise par
les par les français parce que tout le
monde attend d'eux n'est évidemment que
vous soyez dans l'équipe de france
est-ce que vous en voulez aimé jacquet
est ce que vous avez de la haine parce
que finalement votre rêve s'est envolé
ce jour là
non un moment donné j'ai eu de la haine
bien sûr j'aime ou pas de la haine mais
bon oui j'aurais préféré jouer mais
aujourd'hui non je suis innocent j'ai
plus du tout non ingérence et puis ce
qui s'est passé c'est très bien
peut-être que si je vais jouer se serait
pas passé comme ça peut-être que si
j'avais joué se serait passé comme ça ou
peut-être qu'un sens ne soit jamais et
puis c'est bien que ce soit passé comme
ça vous n'êtes pas le sentiment d'être
orphelin de cette victoire d'une
certaine façon
non non j'ai vécu des trucs
extraordinaires des grandes des grandes
joies et des grandes déceptions et ça
fait partie des grandes déceptions et ça
fait partie de la vie ça fait partie des
choses qui nous font avancer
mon alim
alors il ya eu aussi le cantona
autodidacte c'est à dire que chaque à
aix pour vous avez rencontré isabelle
vous à brancher sur la sur le soleil sur
les livres d'une certaine façon ça c'est
un choc pour vous mais j'ai choisi la
femme que
la moitié que je suis pas quoi c'est à
dire le même panneau autodidacte rien
j'ai arrêté l'école très tourelles
besoin de
de la femme qui faisait que deux ont
fait quelque chose de mes choisi je
crois toujours le partenaire qui est ça
dure toujours
c'est dur voit ça fait 15 ans et bien
dire que lorsque on peut reconnaître
quand même c'est que votre carrière sur
le plan du football a été en dents de
scie vous arrive dans un club ou casser
la gueule à un mec vous partez vous
revenez bon et votre femme opte toujours
voilà c'est une grande
famille aurait fait ça parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de femmes de footballeur et
puis je crois qu'il ya un film qui se
prépare à sur les femmes de footballeur
c'est vrai qu'à des
qui n'a jamais prêté à un club
et elle a toujours été là dans les
grands moments mais elle est toujours là
qu'on voit qu'on voit à l'écran très
bien et alors il ya aussi le cantona
peintre c'est dire que votre père en
fait baigner sur votre père il était
infirmier dans une dans une clinique
psychiatrique c'est ça non oui c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'on m'a traité de
fou toute ma carrière ce commentaire
était infirmier en psychiatrie - et
contrairement aux psychiatres 1 ça fait
peur à tout le monde un coup il a fait
me fout parce qu'il était et infirmiers
en psychiatrie depuis qu un peu comme ça
firmi en blouse blanche et vous le savez
je devais être fou ip nier votre père
sur le soir quand ils finiraient il
peignait et vous vous avez voulu vivre
aussi un peu cette folie créative de ça
ne suffisait pas le ballon mais les je
veux pas vivre de folie mais le ballon
ça ne suffisait pas vous aviez envie de
vous exprimer d'autres façons non on a
tous besoin de m mais un tous besoin de
se retrouver seul face à nous mêmes et
puis d'exprimer certains trucs qu'on a
dans la tête parce que c'est là
vraiment la corse connaît vraiment entre
d'anjou toute notre ville et il ya que
dans ces moments là qu'on peut arriver à
faire quelque chose pas de bien ou de
beaux de quoi que ce soit c'est quelque
part une thérapie je pense moi je prends
ça comme de la thérapie c'est
impulsif c'est peut être tendres
j'ai besoin exprimé quelque chose
maintenant si c'est lié que ça plaît à
personne c'est pas grave vraiment à nous
on a besoin de le montrer parce que
c'est comme ça on est tous c'est comme
ça même si j'ai pas montré à grammont
mais les gens de mon entourage oui et
mais ce jugement ne doit pas nous faire
nous trahir nous mêmes mais c'est un
personnage à michel il est entier il est
vrai
fascinant bien alors aujourd'hui vous
occupez de de beach soccer parler tout
ça parce que c'est vrai qu'en france
dans le monde c'est connu en france
c'est moins connu donc d'abord qu'il ya
dans l'équipe
aujourd'hui il ya des mecs qui ont
arrêté ya pas longtemps
comme fourni et comme dirait il ya le
bêta pascal olmeta mon frère joël et
puis d'autres moins connus qui ont été
de bon footballeur mais notre ambition à
nous c'est de pas de social et de se
servir de tous ces joueurs comme ça pour
que chacun développe dans sa région
vraiment un sport où les jeunes joueurs
qu'on compte comme mettre des terrains à
disposition des jeunes puisque c'est ses
intérêts en jeu au pied nu n'est pas ça
coûte rien on joue à cinq contre cinq
c'est ça au brésil c'est très populaire
très cosy sur les plages à des poteaux
ça coûte quoi de mettre deux poteaux sur
une plage les grandes plages qui à tout
surtout cap d'agde ouest où 10 ans là
bas
tous les avocats et moi je fais ça parce
que c'est vraiment un sport c'est un
sport qui me plaît chose rsa sans
intérêt ce qui me plaît c'est de
promouvoir un sport que j'aime parce que
c'est jour de fête c'est beau c'est un
vrai sport cnds avait des coups de pied
retourné pour ça vous arrange parce que
vous êtes acculé en bois débute mois
déjà des gestes spectaculaires dix fois
plus que sur un terrain de foot normal
c'est moins dangereux que ces bons qui
est complètement à part du football mais
je pense que c'est un beau sport oui
j'aime on doit ce sport mais qui étaient
insultés moins dangereux pour lui tape à
deux crampons l'a
alors peu dire que eric cantona est
quand même le meilleur buteur français
dans cette spécialité là aussi que
faisait quatorze buts à votre actif à
vous plaît michel ah oui c'est sympa en
plus davantage c'est que ça joue sur des
plages donc comme ça au moins on le
soleil on n'est pas obligé d'aller
s'emmerder à sedan ou à valenciennes ou
dans les endroits comme ça c'est sa main
si on peut jouer là bas aussi oui mais
couverts indoor indoor island à bien
alors vous avez eu des eaux vous avez eu
des bas et on va faire une interview à
peine d'art
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
obligé de rester vous avez bougé par des
calanques les
sécheresses en afrique et oui on le
bouge faim pendant le génial on
recommence
[Applaudissements]
non mais attendez je croyais que vous
étiez une bonne petite
bourgeoise bien disciplinée temps qui
m'était jamais de porte-jarretelles
jamais de talent seulement dans les
films
voilà aulas bien alors qu'est ce que
vous préférez en vous
si vous préférez en votre qualité
préféré chez vous
on se régale de serre ges non madame de
sagesse l'adresse que vous aimez votre
grande sagesse
qu'est-ce que vous haïssez en vous
madame de sagesse
ce qui vous plaît le plus dans le foot
une supportrice qu'est ce qui vous plaît
le moins
leur mec
dans le cinéma parce qu on la parle n'a
pas parlé ce soir vous avez fait
quelques films à commençant par le
bonheur est dans le pré puis en
terminant donc comme on le disait avec
les enfants du marais bientôt corto
maltese qu'est ce que vous préférez dans
le cinéma
mais j'ai beaucoup rêver et puis
j'aurais moins maintenant mais bon ça ne
peut-être parce que j'ai pas eu besoin
vais-je vu de loin des aventures bien
qu'on ait
annoncé l'ong non je crois que c'est
bien que l'arrivée d'autres comme et
quand on a faim on a eu une vie intense
comme celle d'un sportif de haut niveau
au sein attendre attendre le moment où
le réel il ne touche que chasser banque
en fait pourquoi non parce que je
n'avais jamais vécu le truc que
j'entends parler moi on dirait que c'est
des extraterrestres alors même que moi
je n'ai pas vécu ça ouais des montées de
trucs et de partir dans un délire de
machines de notre quatre ans j'ai jamais
vécu ça doit exister mais je dois être
assez bons pour ça donc c'est passé pas
obligatoire c'est parfait pour moi c'est
pas mémorable qu'il n'y a pas de moi je
me rappelle de deux gestes de moments de
de foot extraordinaire sans doute parce
que c'était ma vraie passion et que le
cinéma c'est dans ma vraie passion et
plus de jetons mais je pense qu'il ya
des jouets les vrais acteurs ou les gens
pour qui c'est la passion ils ont
peut-être ces moments mais pas moi votre
match préféré c'était quoi non quand je
suis revenue peut-être après ma
suspension contre liverpool ouais et
celui que j'avais détesté la bulgarie
c'était rival c'était
messi ont ce qu'on se demande ce qui
même pas où on peut quand même pas qu'on
sait on y croyait pas quoi wen a fait un
cauchemar quand même et ça dure ça dure
et encore aujourd'hui en allemagne si
c'est vrai waze est dit est ce que je
vais me réveiller oui après le
voilà mais ce qui s'est passé même pas
une déception quand c'est une peur d'eux
d'abord pas savoir vraiment si on vit la
réalité c'est ce qu'on est en train de
vivre
ce que vous préférez dans la vie c'est
quoi être bien avec les gens que j'aime
et que je sente que ceux qui s'expriment
comme ils ont envie de s'exprimer que je
me sente moi vraiment libre de dire quoi
que ce soit je le lendemain je me
réveillais pas me disant ça va ça arrive
à se raconter ça ou ça ou ça j'ai choisi
mon entourage pense que je me suis bien
entouré j'ai mes amis et
je peux faire ce que je veux vivre la
vie que je veux dans l'intimité avec ces
gens là ça me dire que je vais être
jugée sur quoi que ce soit est ce que
fait le plus chier dans la vie c'est
quoi
ben c'est de voir de devoir chercher
pendant tous ces trucs
[Rires]
si vous avez alors ce que vous avez le
plus c'est un peu chiant encore des plus
sexy en vous à votre avis c'est quoi
j'aime danser mais je trouve ça c'est
sensuel c'est je pense que quelqu'un qui
bouge bien qu'ils aiment danser qui cale
au rythme comme ça ça allait
obligatoirement ray quelques noms
essentielle
quelle soirée après laine de football
voici ce que faisait de moins sexy en
bout je me voyais comme vraiment
quelqu'un de sexy moi je me suis jamais
demandé si j'avais qu'est ce que
j'aimerais c'est
rassurez-vous eric cantona on arrive on
arrive à la dernière question qui
évidemment celle que tout le monde
attend qu'est ce que vous préférez dans
le sexe mon plaisir on se le plaisir de
l'autre à écouter ça allait si je fais
rien fait et que je sens que mon
partenaire prend du plaisir à semer des
réserves et jeu et
c'est pas obligatoire mais c'est ce vers
quoi je vous tendait j'essaye la
mackellerie une grande marque un grand
hic le fait d'espérer saignant moment
vous marquez
tandis que vous testez d'un siècle
maintenant
ce que je déteste ouais
enfin il a un verbe ne seraient plus
heureux quand ils écoutent la mer les
mouettes match pour y répondre le conte
comme pato a rencontré que je viens de
vous dire voilà voilà c'est ça en fait
qu'est ce que c'est que ce jeudi
pourquoi tu as devant partenaires mon
partenaire parce que c'est ma forme
bergé mais ma femme ou ma partenaire
wydad qui coûtera cher dans la presse
deux grands types de cantona tard logea
jeu
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux